We're standing in front of the building that
houses the Commission on Presidential Debates,
back in 2000 they said 'hey you gotta be at
15% in five national polls that we pick.'
Gary Johnson and Bill Weld, they did not cut
it with the American public, they're at 8.6-8.4%
according to real clear politics, why should
they be in?
The polls were not correct, they didn't ask
about him on the first question, I read all
the methodologies, and there, his name was
buried down deep into the questions and also
the CNN / ORC poll that came out, if you look
at every single page from 18-34 year olds
it was N/A so they didn't get enough statistical
data to even represent it.
Certain polls have under-represented 35 and
under,
other polls have under-represented independents.
Independents make up half of the voting population
in the United States and some polls only polled
Democrats and Republicans and they only included
about 15% representation from Independents.
There's a groundswell of opinion in this country
that we need multi-party politics or third
party politics and it just so happens that,
you know, history has set the table with Johnson/Weld,
it's such a strong ticket that if these guys
can't be the damn-breakers to get us, you
know, to multi-party politics, nobody's going
to.
But I got to tell you it's the extremists
on both sides that are ruining America.
So you see Gary Johnson and Bill Weld as centrists,
you know, because normally the knock on Libertarians
is that, they're these crazy people out there
on the horizon talking about, you know, selling
crack cocaine in grammar school.
I just, I don't, I see their side of it.
But I'm not gonna agree with any candidate
100%,
the only person I'm gonna agree with 100% of the time is myself.
So, barring that, I align myself to Johnson/Weld
more than any other.
I don't agree with everything Gary Johnson
has to say.
But right now he's the only one in the middle,
he's only Libertarian who has any chance of
getting on the national stage and saying,
like 'Hey, we can agree to disagree.
But the number one priority in America has
to be liberty.'
What do you like most about Gary Johnson?
That he's speaking honestly about the issues
I'm concerned about which are the tax code
and how complicated it's become and social
security which needs to be reformed.
I believe he's the best choice for our country.
And I want a smaller government, hopefully
want to get some of the troops home,
stop all the stupid wars.
You said earlier, you drove all the way from
Boston, that is some kinda commitment, would
you do that for any other presidential candidate?
Absolutely not.
I am outraged at the thought of a Clinton
or Trump presidency.
I think it's embarrassing, I think it's embarrassing
for America that we are going to have people
that are known crooks and liars speaking for
us and basically being our American icon.
Well we're here protesting the decision not
to let Gary debate and obviously we all want
Gary on that stage with the other two candidates.
And we wouldn't mind seeing Jill up there
too.
Johnson's views align with mine very well.
Any small L libertarian republican, and I
think that's a huge part of the party, would
be happy to support him.
But I also think that we're teaching our kids
to vote for bad people.
We're telling our children 'the two party
system has nominated these two candidates
and they're your only choice' and everyone
who supports those two candidates I hear them
saying 'yeah I hate my candidate but they're
less of a liar than the other candidate.'
And less of a liar is not a good reason to
vote for someone.
He's now on all 50 ballots plus the District
of Columbia, and I think it's imperative for
the American people to understand truly what
their choice is and they do have an alternative
choice to Trump and Hillary.
Are you a, traditionally are you a Republican,
a Democrat, Libertarian, where do you fall?
I've always been a Democrat, and always voted
that way.
What do you think explains his immense popularity
among younger people?
Well, of course, Libertarians were a little
worried with the Bernie phenomenon, that the
milleniums who liked Ron Paul just four and
eight years ago were suddenly going socialist.
But, you know, their concern about Hillary
I think is making them look at Gary or Jill
Stein and seeing his liberal positions on
a lot of social issues, whether it's the drug
war or intervention overseas, regime change,
or privacy, you know, the surveillance state,
over-criminalization, a host of issues where
Governor Johnson is better than Hillary on.
I've never done this, we're not activists.
I've never even put a bumper sticker on my
car, I've never donated to a campaign.